I wanted to watch Tana's response to the
idubbb apology and it says idubbbz has
apologized to Tana Mojo and I don't know
how I feel about it you know because
like Tim inevitably making me kind of
canceled and lose subscribers and have
to apologize and all that type of stuff
I I kind of think I like deserved that
and maybe that's like dark like to say I
don't feel like I'm owed an apology and
maybe that's because I've accepted it so
much that like people always ask me if
you could go back in time and like make
that never happen like would you and I
always say no because I feel like at the
time it was obviously like it was a very
dark time period of my life when it came
to like self-reflection and trying to
figure out and like I think I would
be a completely different person if I
didn't have that I think it like I was
on track to just be so on my high horse
and like egotistical and like nothing
could go wrong that something going
wrong gave me such a dose of reality
that like this might not last forever